welcome to net 101 hybrid networking for
millions of users with TCP and Twitter
engineering
my name is Cynthia Thomas I'm a
networking specialist at Google cloud
and I'm a company by Todd hi I'm Todd
Segal I'm a software engineer at Twitter
working on traffic and our engine for
structure today we're gonna talk to you
about how Twitter and manages traffic to
handle millions of tweets and leverages
Google networking to augment their
capacity let's get into it
Twitter is leveraging Google cloud
products that are built on Google's
proven infrastructure they're probably
able to recognize some of these logos
here who supported over a billion users
on nine products all relying on Google
networking infrastructure we've learned
a lot and innovated a lot to be able to
achieve such scale while ensuring
reliability speed and security that
means better reliability and performance
than the public internet and other cloud
providers through this experience we've
been able to develop protocols that
improve networking performance like bbr
and quick bbr improves the previous TCP
congestion algorithm which was based on
packet loss instead Google has designed
an algorithm to respond to actual
congestion for available bandwidth and
minimal round-trip times for huge
performance games another example of
Google networking innovation is quic
based on UDP and transport layer
protocol that's it reduces latency by
eliminating the number of handshakes
compared to HTTPS over TCP Twitter and
Google cloud users already benefit from
these higher throughput lower latency
gains by accessing Google manage
services like BigTable and cloud storage
are the current numbers we have 24 cloud
regions across the globe and several are
coming down the fight
as you can see Google's made a large
investment in infrastructure globally
including undersea cables cloud
regions partnerships of ISPs to deploy
pops and CD ends at the edge we continue
to grow our data center and and cloud
region count each year this benefit
means we can rely on Google engineering
to deploy reliably and securely across
the globe it's a benefit for example a
Twitter user anywhere in the world for a
better user experience here we can see
Google has made a sizable investment in
physical infrastructure globally Google
has built its own backbone providing
private connectivity between Google
cloud region's data centers and such
just as Twitter is leveraged Google
infrastructure for cloud services like
cloud BigTable and networking cloud
storage cool cloud users can also
benefit from cool O's dedicated
infrastructure for performance and
security as Todd will discuss Twitter is
complemented in its own infrastructure
by bursting and adding capacity using
Google's global footprints Twitter is
already taking advantage of Google edge
networking including our pops4 dedicated
private dedicated interconnects peering
and our Google friends for caching load
balancing and securing against DDoS at
the edge one major differentiator for
Google cloud networking is the shared
global VPC model so Twitter takes
advantage of this model where the shared
VPC allows centralized management of
Google cloud networking so that means
subnets and routes can are reachable
o'clock across the entire global of VPC
which means great ease of management
while never traversing the public
Internet additionally this means you can
deploy Google global constructs like the
Google float Google global load
balancers to deploy any Kassovitz
minimizing the amount of configuration
and providing a great end-user
experience
so there's a host of Google cloud
networking products and capabilities
that Google cloud provides powered by
our proven infrastructure we have
various ways to connect your on-prem to
our cloud secure your workloads with
numerous security options and scale
applications through our load balancers
and cloud CDN and furthermore take
advantage of orchestrating workloads
through open store open source standard
platforms like kubernetes and sto the
roots of which come from Google so
during this talk we'll discuss some of
the edge networking features that
Twitter leverages from Google to scale
this includes the Google global load
balancer and cloud CDN next table we'll
get into how Twitter deploys at the edge
thanks Cynthia so I'm gonna talk a
little bit about Twitter's edge network
before we expanded our network with with
Google and some of the issues that we
were facing and how we solved them so
Twitter's Global edge network is made of
multiple points of presence deployed
throughout the world and we also have a
global backbone network that this edge
connects to the edge then forwards
traffic on to our serving regions that
are located in a few different places
throughout the world when we originally
deployed this network we had different
IP addresses in different locations
unicast IPs or regional IPs and then we
would have different DNS responses based
on where the user was we eventually
change this to be globally anycast FIPS
which greatly improved availability
because of some of the issues with DNS
caching were imprecise geolocation so
availability was good at this point
however performance wasn't always good
so some of the challenges that we've run
into are first of all anycast is
optimized by by the carrier's by the
individual service providers they can
set their own policies twitter can't
necessarily control making sure that a
certain service provider provides the
the best
various for Twitter users versus other
users the service provider may optimize
for their own traffic or for different
types of traffic versus Twitter traffic
another issue is with capacity in with
location getting close to the users if
Twitter wants to add a new location on
our network we have to do a lot of
research and we have to incur a lot of
costs in engineering so it's difficult
if the World Cup is going to be in a new
location where we don't have good
connectivity or a good pup or I'm sorry
a local pop or the Olympics are going to
be somewhere again where it's
challenging for Twitter users to connect
it's difficult for us to quickly at a
new location especially if it's going to
be somewhere temporary when we just need
a burst of capacity let's look a little
bit into some of the problems with
anycast IPS that we've seen so with our
anycast IPs
our end users so here let's assume that
this purple icon is a user somewhere in
Europe that's trying to connect with the
Twitter edge they have the Twitter
global anycast IP and that edge can
resolve to one of in different regions
one of n different edges that exists in
Europe it's up to kind of this blog we
call the Internet to figure out if this
will go to edge a or HP in the path it
takes to get there and this blob is
actually made up of lots of different
hops individual service providers
transit providers and various agreements
between them on how traffic is rabid and
this can change throughout the course of
a day and based on a variety of settings
that are made by people frequently so
the path from the end user to Twitter is
not always going to be the most optimal
path additionally when Twitter has to
send the response back to the end user
Twitter can just choose the first hop
back then that one may take a circuitous
circuitous route back to the end user
again both of these directions may not
be optimal at a given point in time they
could be based on time of day network
feedback round robin algorithms of
things so this is pretty good for
availability but it's not great for
latency furthermore it doesn't always
seem logical to our engineers or at
least to me
this chart shows where requests from
users in South Korea which Twitter edged
the requests ended up on in the course
of a day during the course of a day I
personally would have expected almost
all of the requests to show up at our
edge location which is in eastern Asia
we have multiple locations in Asia I
would have expected that the South
Korean user request would end up there
turned out only about 40% only about 60%
of requests ended up there where the
other 40% of requests ended up going to
Europe or going to the US we also
noticed a lot of deviation in the
overall latency histograms larger
standard deviation some of this is
attributed to the return path that
Twitter was taking or just some of these
really long paths that the user requests
for taking so improvements that we've
made to mitigate some of these problems
one of them has been to expand our edge
by using the public lab specifically the
Google cloud the Google load balancers
so I this has really increased our
global footprint so however many pops we
had before now we also have the entire
Google pop network as well to ingress
user traffic with all of Google's BGP
optimizations and peering agreements
with the various service providers and
the return paths as well also we've
acknowledged that we can't control
making sure that service providers
provide the optimal path from a specific
user to Twitter so what we've decided to
do is we've set up a variety of
different bits instead of a single
global anycast bit or a single set of
global anycast pips and what we've done
is we measure all of these different
bits and then we can optimize how an
individual user connects to Twitter by
planning the best bit for that user so
looking back at this diagram again the
end user we can give them our global
anycast web they can connect through the
Internet through all of those hops and
end up at NJ or edge V and then we can
return it to them we can also provide
another VIP in this case this VIP
also took the same path to edge a but
perhaps in this case
Twitter's BGP policy says that the
return path will always go to a specific
provider and we can measure how this
read in this black path are performing
over the course of the day we can prefer
one of the other four individual end
users we can also set up any cast pips
so that our user is making a request and
it forces them to land on edge B in this
case or perhaps it doesn't work we can
again measure it and we can provide this
if it's a good option for the end user
also we can set up lots and lots of VIPs
in the public cloud that route to Google
edges and then also provide Google
various ways to route back to Twitter
and measure all of these as well the
system we've set up that uses real-time
measurements to choose from one of
hundreds of different dips or routes
back to Twitter for individual end users
we call it the traffic control tower we
steer individual users to the best fit
for them at that moment and we use a
variety of information we use netbox
something that's ISP identifiers and
country codes to figure out how to group
measurements together we're able to
route around problems that we see in the
internet were able to define optimized
routes from a user to Twitter and back
and it's proven very effective for us
I'm going to hand it back over to
Cynthia to talk a bit about the Google
Network and then we'll look at how
Twitter specifically uses the Google
edge
all right thanks Don
so yes Tom mentioned the Internet can
definitely present itself with an
inconsistent behavior on the traffic
path so clearly the network matters and
it's really important to the end user
experience with Google's private
backbone we can provide two types of
networking tiers so there's the standard
and premium tier so the premium tier is
a unique combination of providing speed
and reliability I'm writing the Google
private
so the the best analogy is pretty much
like a hot potato cold potato type
behavior so the alt the default
alternate behavior would be like old hot
potato getting rid of the packet and
handing off the Internet as soon as
possible whereas with the Google premium
tier we basically hang on to the packet
as long as possible
deliver it write it over our private
backbone and then deliver it as close to
the destination or user as possible so
this enables basically a better
reliability performance security and
this better user experience so one
networking contract that Google provides
is the global load balancer with anycast
fit so this load balancer can use two
for global reach for users to quickly
enter the Google backbone and
infrastructure and in traverse the
private network to its destination it
provides worldwide and capacity cross
region failover and fast auto scaling
and the ability to provide handled
millions of queries per second so
Twitter actually leverages the Google
cloud load bouncer for edge reach
ability of services and this basically
this goal this global load balancer can
be combined with both cloud CDN and
cloud armor for both caching and
security services while scaling so one
powerful behavior of the global load
balancer is that the cross region
failover the overflow to other regions
so traffic is actually proxy to backends
by a special algorithm called the
waterfall by treating so if an entire
region reaches capacity the the
waterfall by a region algorithm is
triggered and traffic can overflow to
the closest region with available
capacity and traffic can also be
preemptively overflown to other regions
an event of unhealthy backends and this
sort of magic I just want to talk a
little bit about the negs
so Network endpoint groups this was
introduced actually helps a lot in
containerized environments where without
names there was
and I tables rule that would hop from
one node to another so there's this
extra health introduced network in five
groups is basically a collection of
endpoints defined as an IP port pair
this allows things like pods to be
directly reachable as backends to the
global load balancer so what's
interesting about that is you can use an
eggs and other definitions as well like
internet and eggs which would align to
endpoints that are actually outside of
your client so next Tod we'll get into
the details of how Twitter uses Google
cloud load balancing in their
deployments thanks Cynthia so there's
two primary ways that Twitter uses the
Google edge so we use Google's top
network which is all over the world and
we accept to technically two types of
requests through the load balancer one
is layer four only and the other is
layer seven so in this first example
we're looking at how Twitter uses
Google's TCP proxy so in this case the
Google edge closest to the user that
will steer the user to based on our
traffic control tower system will
terminate TCP for the end user establish
a persistent connection with a Twitter
service which is running in GCP the
Google compute region and then we will
then proxy that TCP connection back to
one of many Twitter VIPs in this diagram
here you see there's a blue a purple and
an orange v that the Twitter service and
TCP will hand off to these represent
different paths back to Twitter so some
of them write on the Google backbone as
far as possible
some of them hand off as quickly as
possible from Google to the Twitter
backbone or or private interconnect so
in this case using layer 4 only provide
some additional security for Twitter in
cases where we want the certificate to
always remain in the in the Twitter pub
or in the Twitter infrastructure or else
it provides us with some additional
compatibility if we have some Twitter
clients that have
Twitter only level 7 behavior various
protocol idiosyncrasies etc additionally
we use Google pretty heavily as a layer
7 proxy and we get multiple benefits in
this case so again we set up multiple
lips that all correspond to the
worldwide Google edge and the different
lips use the internet Meg that Cynthia
was talking about before to route back
to one of n different Twitter back-end
Becky's and these IPS again they
correspond to different routes back to
Twitter either over the Google backbone
or over the Twitter backbone and again
we measure those and send the user to
whichever one could be performing the
best or perhaps where we need additional
capacity and I'll talk about that
shortly in this case as you can see the
Google edge does everything there's no
service that twitter has to run inside
GCP there's no deployments we have to do
there's no monitoring we have to do
besides overall Google load balance or
multi monitoring so this has been really
great for us and reduced the amount of
operations and deployments that we've
had to do to do GCP let's take a look at
what this is done for our end users with
the combination of the control tower and
expanding our edge to regions in two
locations in the public cloud we've been
able to pretty dramatically improve the
performance for many of our users this
graph here shows the improvements at
various percentiles p25 b75 p99 for
users in different countries and this
represents the user measured at home
timeline request latency and end so it
includes all the backend latency the
connection establishment latency transit
latency etc etc as you can see in all of
these countries we've pretty
dramatically improved some of the didn't
even some of the earlier percentile
related ceased as well we've seen this
correspond to to greater
satisfaction and usage of Twitter in
these regions as well as failures have
gone down and request success rate has
gone up and lindsey's went down one
additional benefit from using the public
cloud edges from using Google load
balancer has been additional capacity
that we've gotten to use with no
deployments on our end this chart comes
from a recent event in South America
there's a reality TV show called Big
Brother Brazil that recently set the the
Guinness Book of World Records most
online votes it took this away from
American Idol I believe and this purple
line here shows the number of requests
that happened at the peak of voting
during this show the number of requests
Twitter and the red line of the bottom
shows how much Twitter on Prem capacity
we have in South America and this peak
was actually three times the amount of
on from capacity that that we have so if
we weren't able to burst into the public
cloud and spill over into our other
regions Twitter likely would have been
just hard down for the entire continent
of South America and by using the
control tower to to steer users to
public cloud endpoints and spill over
bits and other things that are
performing well we not only kept Twitter
successfully up but we were able to keep
tortor up with really fantastic
performance for end-users at this time
let me hand it off to to Cynthia to talk
about about the traffic director and
Hybrid networking so yeah let's talk a
little bit of a traffic director for
those who don't know traffic director is
and manage control plane enabling global
services with various types of backends
and GZ keys
so that could include GCE instances or
gke and it programmatically configures
envoy proxies so it actually leverages
the Google cloud load balancer and this
is a powerful way to serve applications
globally the Google Network traffic
director additionally allows for hybrid
connectivity as it has the capability to
route traffic to
on GCP back ends so it's an additional
way Twitter can direct traffic to its
datacenters all right thanks for
watching our talk we made it to the end
we hope you learned a little bit about
how Twitter scales with Google edge
networking wanted to also if you wanted
more information about traffic director
their follow up talks that will dive
deeper into your traffic director
capabilities almost many of the other
networking talks I want to also have a
special thanks to Todd and the Twitter
team for walking us through how to our
edge deployment is using Google cloud
great thanks so much Cynthia and a big
thank you to Cynthia into the Google
team on this great partnership we have
more resources about the traffic control
tower and how Twitter uses the Google
edge in the public cloud up on the
Twitter engineering blog so check that
out and enjoy the other talks and thank
you very much this was fun